[Music]  I was born by the special riddle of  heaven to restore the lust age of  chivalry  I am Don Quixote de la Mancha good work  I want to drop some of the shots why  because it isn't working because my  client isn't happy does the whole  concept is ridiculous you are Don  Quixote it's your concept of your vision  keep an eye on her do that for me I'm  the boss's wife  [Music]  of year Raju you're crazy peasant you  think you can hide from me we shall have  such great adventures together  I am Don Quixote de la Mancha and I  command you to release my square about  the hoodie Wow now he actually believes  he's done here this is going to be fun  [Music]  don quixote de la mancha come to restore  the lost age of he's probably wet  himself I don't like this why does  everything always have to be about you  [Music]  you